nevada governor sysolak weighing in on  troubles at the school district the  governor says he's following everything  in the news and is urging the school  board to find the right solution for  students and families in mind the thing  that you know my concern is relates to  ccsd is the kids you know there's an  awful lot of kids that are going to  school now and they need stability the  parents need to know that there's  stability and that's what we're going to  focus on  catching up with him there at the ribbon  cutting of the new fountain blue the  governor said it might be time for  lawmakers to take another look at the  governing models of school boards in the  next legislative session